and cue the crazy old lizard
good morning mr. moon I got Judith from
the bank on line two actually a math car
back my theaters been going through some
pretty rough times so what do I do a car
wash no my next show is gonna be
drumroll please a singing competition
who wants to see another one of those
everyone your neighbor the the grocery
store manager that that that chicken
right there real talent from real life
that's what audience is one and I'm
gonna get a tool do you ever feel feel
so paper hi mommy
Merman would you please tell them what a
good singer I am oh yeah you were great
honey
by the way the bathroom sink is blocked
again by honey in your mind could you
ever be really close to me sure you were
supposed to be clear on the pass sorry
dad
birthday to you if I had a voice like
Mina's I'd be a superstar by now just
singing oh yeah sure he wouldn't
grandfather now blow out your candles
hmm how do with those Flyers miss
Crawley
this will be the biggest hit show this
city has ever seen everyone gets a shot
at being a store live on my stage I'm
here win that prize it's mine go home
see you're really funny looking
that's all right cut oh my gosh look at
her butt oh my gosh look at her are you
okay oh yes I'm fine thank you
how are you this is it folks you better
be ready to work harder than you've ever
worked in your lives yes that was very
bad we've got the shows a viral design
the fire went out a long time ago you
are not gonna believe what I did today
Bob I don't want to be in your gang I
wanna be a singer how did I end up with
a son aren't you
you just got it now
this song is not gonna save your theater
maybe it's time to move on you know how
much this means to us just
he thanked is about to explode with
major piggy power
you know what's great about hitting rock
bottom there's only one way left to go
and that's
Oh
DiBiase
it's bleeding in Aisle 6 that was
awesome
they're bleep set pipes our conscience
me Oh Oh tell me skin